und schon haben wir den nächsten bahn
fall andré weber aus remscheid hat uns
auch eine video frage geschickt
ich habe am 14 januar 2020 eine
gruppenreise zum super sparpreis von rem
statt nach münchen gebucht und es geht
bei uns um insgesamt 1500 53 euro und 40
cent seine mannschaft uhr
es macht mich wirklich wütend wenn ich
mir überlege dass die deutsche bahn uns
hier keine kulanz möglichkeit in form
eines gutscheins oder sonstiges gibt die
kulanzregelung der deutschen bahn gelten
ausschliesslich bis vierten fünften und
darüber hinaus ist es einfach pech wir
dürfen nicht fahren wir dürfen es nicht
wie sie mit 13 personen uns in der
öffentlichkeit aufhalten wir machen uns
strafbar
bitte helft uns vielleicht können wir
uns unterstützen und auch da haben wir
uns natürlich eingeschaltet die bahn
grundsätzlich sagt die aktuellen
umfangreichen sonder kulanz gehen
deutlich über unsere tariflichen
verpflichtungen hinaus bei dieser
mannschafts reise ist das problem
natürlich auch das abstandsregelung im
zug möglicherweise nicht eingehalten
werden können
und wir haben zumindest den hinweis dass
natürlich alle fußballmannschaften oder
alle diejenigen die mit einer gruppe
unterwegs sind die dürfen bis zum 31
oktober flexibel reisen also umbuchen
aber natürlich das grundproblem bleibt
man darf sich halt mit größeren gruppen
nicht zusammen
in den waggons ohne sicherheitsabstand
einhalten
da gelten halt corona regeln die auch
nicht die deutsche bahn zu verantworten
hat ich glaube aber auch sofern diese
fußball reise verschoben werden kann
glaube ich ist da auch dieser fall
eigentlich als gelöst abzuhaken
das heißt also die bahn hat hier jetzt
schon einiges erreicht und wir haben sie
stehen mit der bahn auch in kontakt
haben sie auch probleme da waren einfach
1414 bild.de